the glass castle comes to us from the
director of short-term 12 and its star
brie Larson and also stars Woody
Harrelson and Naomi Watts as the
nonconformist parents to a family that
they are constantly dragging around from
abandoned house to abandoned house
they're fleeing the law they don't
really want to work they don't want to
be involved in the corporate system they
feel that that is a giant lie we get to
see young Jeannette and her brother and
sisters raised in a very difficult
household that is in constant motion
this is based off of the true memoir
written by Jeannette Walls herself and
it's all about how hard it was to live
in that type of lifestyle and in this
film we start out in 1989 and we see
adult Jeannette played by brie Larson
and we flash back and forth from the
past to the present there's considerable
talent in front of the camera and behind
it with this movie which is why it's so
disappointing that I found this film so
dull and meandering it's a film that
tries to be a lot more because it's
story is ripe with a lot of drama and
emotion but it feels almost gutted like
they just want to focus on specific
things her father's alcoholism was the
biggest cloud that hung over their
family and so the film focuses on that
quite a bit and then so doing it gives
the character wrecks portrayed by Woody
Harrelson the most development Naomi
Watts plays the mother in the film who
is a painter and nothing else really she
doesn't get paid for her work she's
perfectly fine watching her kids eating
nothing but butter and sugar mixed
together on a plate
this film presents all of the horrible
aspects of Jeannette to youth and every
once in a while it will show what we're
supposed to believe is the good her
father uses hope as a way to convince
them that they're not completely poverty
stricken to look up to the stars and say
which one of those do you want for
Christmas I'll give it to you and the
young kids are so blinded to what's
actually going on that they think that's
really cool and really amazing the issue
I have with the filmmaking of these
scenes is that the musical score that
underlies them is trying to tell us that
it's a happy moment when it's actually
rather tragic and sad it's extreme
léa hard to watch this father and mother
basically allow their kids to not eat
for days take their money put them in
dangerous situations and do nothing
about it really but the film keeps
trying to tell us to be uplifted by
these scenarios that's not how we should
be feeling while watching these
situations this movie should have been
really dark and really sharp-edged
unfortunately it comes off like a glassy
hallmark drama where the music swells
and we get really uplifted by
heartwarming moments and some people
will really enjoy this film some of the
people sitting next to me were crying
their eyes out at many parts but I found
a film that could have been considerably
more impactful emotionally but it rings
with no authenticity because it doesn't
understand the darkness that's actually
happening in these scenes and it plays a
lot of them for comedy unfortunately
which really misses the mark now that's
not to say the film does not explore the
darker aspects of what went on with this
family they do very much so go into the
father's alcoholism there's a really
nasty situation with the grandmother
that's not left alone but all of it
feels rather surface-level
it never feels like they really got
under the surface of just how terrible
this family situation was you see a lot
of bad things happen but you don't feel
that it's happening to these characters
it just seems like we're told well that
happened that's unfortunate we see the
same basic scenario played out over and
over and over and it becomes so dull and
OneNote that by the end of this movie I
had checked my watch probably six or
seven times it's far too long and
whenever it flashes back to the present
day which in this case of 1989 I found
myself even less interested in adult
Jeanette's
situation it was just a very boring film
and it's unfortunately dull there's a
film that came out recently called
Captain Fantastic with Viggo Mortensen
that had similar themes was he taking
proper care of his children by keeping
away from society that film was
different though there was a moral
ambiguity that was present in cats and
fantastic that just isn't present in the
glass castle as the film draws to a
close it asks you to feel a certain way
about the characters and I just couldn't
feel that way what I had seen just
didn't justify that uplifted feeling it
felt too much like a hallmark or a
Lifetime channel original movie
unfortunately it has some good
performances in it but beyond that is
very disappointing I'm going to give the
glass castle a c-minus guys thank you so
much as always for watching look forward
to more Stephen King reviews this
weekend as always you're the best and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck menage
[Music]
Oh